I'm picturing this as a kind of 007 entry.
Both the Republican and Democratic establishments
were shaken by the New Hampshire primary,
which had Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders
clearly and convincingly in the lead.
The Democratic establishment will stay in
Hilary Clinton's corner, especially since
there still remains a doubt about whether
Sanders can win Black and Hispanic Democrats
in large numbers.
He didn't have to do that to win New Hampshire,
but he would have to do it to win the Democratic
nomination.
The situation's a lot murkier on the Republican
side.
Republicans still don't want Donald Trump
as their nominee for the most part, but the
party establishment isn't sure who to get
behind instead.
Ted Cruz who beat Trump in Iowa, is disliked
by many members of the party establishment,
and the party establishment hasn't decided
whether it prefers John Kasich, Marco Rubio,
or Jeb Bush to be their champion.
South Carolina will tell us which of them
that they pick, and set up the possibility
of a three person race going forward.
It's right on zero.
Do you think that Sanders and Trump will win
the nomination, or will the establishment
ultimately prevail?
Let us know in the comments, and let us know
also if you think there are any other topics
that AEI scholars should cover in 60 seconds.